so just as a reminder of where we are
we've got this very non-linear
transformation and we showed that if you
zoom in on a specific point while that
transformation is happening it looks a
lot like something linear and we reason
that you can figure out what linear
transformation that looks like by taking
the partial derivatives of your given
function the one that i defined up here
and then turning that into a matrix and
what i want to do here is basically just
finish up what i was talking about by
computing all of those partial
derivatives so first of all let me just
rewrite the function back on the screen
so we have it in a convenient place to
look at the first component is x
plus sine of y
sine of y and then
y
plus sine of x was the second component
so what i want to do here is just
compute all of those partial derivatives
to show what kind of thing this looks
like
so let's go ahead and get rid of this
word
then i'll go ahead and
kind of redraw the matrix here so for
that upper left component we're taking
the partial derivative with respect to x
of the first component so we look up at
this first component and the partial
derivative with respect to x is just one
since there's one times x plus something
that has nothing to do with x and then
below that we take the partial
derivative of the second component with
respect to x down here and that guy the
y well that looks like a constant so
nothing happens and the derivative of
sine of x becomes cosine
of x
and then up here we're taking the
partial derivative with respect to y of
the first component that upper one here
and for that you know partial derivative
of x with respect to y is zero and
partial derivative of sine of y with
respect to y
is cosine
of y
and then finally the partial derivative
of the second component with respect to
y looks like one
because it's just one times y plus some
constant
and this is the general jacobian as a
function of x and y but if we want to
understand what happens around the
specific point that started off at well
i think i recorded it here at negative 2
1 we plug that into each one of these
values so when we plug in negative 2 1
so go ahead and just kind of again
rewrite it to remember we're plugging in
negative 2 1 as our specific point
that matrix as a function kind of a
matrix-valued function becomes
1 and then next we have cosine but we're
plugging in negative 2 for x cosine of
negative 2. and if you're curious that
is approximately equal to i calculated
this earlier
negative 0.8
if you just want to think in terms of a
number there
then for the upper right we have cosine
again
but now we're plugging in the value for
y which is 1
and cosine of 1 is approximately equal
to
0.54
and then bottom right that's just
another constant 1.
so that is the matrix just as a matrix
full of numbers
and just as kind of a gut check we can
take a look at the linear transformation
this was supposed to look like and
notice how the first basis vector the
thing it got turned into which is this
vector here
does look like it has coordinates 1 and
negative 0.42 right it's got this
rightward component that's about as long
as the vector itself started and then
this downward component which i think
that's you know pretty believable that
that's negative 0.42
and then likewise this second column is
telling us what happened to that second
basis vector which
is the one that looks like this and
again it's it's y component is about as
long as how it started right a length of
one and then the rightward component is
around half of that
and we actually see that in the diagram
but this is something you compute again
it's pretty straightforward you just
take all of the possible partial
derivatives and you organize them into a
grid like this
so with that i'll see you guys next
video